Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie everybody's freaking
out about Justice league and the Batman movie
there's a whole bunch of rumors going around
so I wanted to explain everything.
It's not as bad as you think.
Do not freak out.
Hopefully it will help you chill out new round
of the flash ring giveaway going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
I know everybody's freaking out right now
but I'm going to countdown going to explain
what's going on where everything is when the
trailer is going to be coming, do not worry
so number 10.
There were rumors circulating that the Batman
movie is gonna be delayed in Justice league
is a mess.
Now, when you actually can investigate these
is really like somebody who knows someone
who is someone on the set is very unverified
yet to take it with a grain of salt.
Usually the source for info on this is really
shady.
So what we do know is that delaying movies
you however long is usually a good thing because
it means they have more time to get things
right.
That was one of the big problems with suicide
squad they just didn't have enough time to
get a really good script and that's really
what people of been talking about for the
Batman movie like is the script on is there
a scripted all yes there's a script in one
of the Aqua man screenwriters actually leaked
a bunch of information about the DC movies
including Justice league saying all the things
that you want to hear.
So this is actually what is quote was.
I hope I'm not going to get in trouble for
saying this, but it's much more fun much popular
thing that pops much more than Batman view
Superman he says that he hasn't seen wonder
woman, but he's basically saying that the
somber tone of Batman view Superman is now
sort of like the bottom of the benchmark.
Everything else is getting way more hopeful
way more fun, so wonder woman is going to
be a really fun movie but really, once we
get to Justice league that's going to be the
kind of fun summer movie that you would want
to go see even though it's coming out during
November.
That's the funny thing is kind of a summer
movie.
But it's coming out late in the year.
He also talked a little about the Aqua man
movie.
People are calling it a swashbuckling adventure,
which it sounds like a ton of fun, we can
talk more about Hawkman in another movie but
respected people are saying that the movies
are doing fine, so I would trust that number
nine kenaf like literally just went on Jimmy
Kimmel, because of all the drama last week
with people quoting and saying that he might
not direct Justice league.
I was like the headline that was going around.
I made a funny video about it how Ben Affleck
is just having fun with people, just trolling
a little bit he is totally gonna direct the
Batman movie.
And this is the quote from Jimmy Kimmel going
to direct the the next about that right next
that were working on for five nights of the
year and 1/2 to write it.
Get ready and I worked really hard and this
is the beginning I wasn't worth like you.
So feel little bit better about this number
eight what was all that business last week
about him not doing it.
That was mostly him just saying that were
not gonna start until the script is ready.
We don't want to fall into the same trap again
because it's no secret that a lot of big Hollywood
movies not just, comic book movies start shooting
the movie before the script is finished.
The other really good example.
This is Star Trek beyond they were actually
writing pages as they were shooting scenes
on days during that film.
It is crazy to think that they would start
making $150 million felt without finishing
the script.
So the more time you had to work on things
the better number seven though the script.
Worst case scenario the Batman script takes
a little bit longer to finish and they just
start shooting later this year they were originally
supposed to start shooting this summer.
That means that you know it takes a couple
more months to finish the script, they just
start shooting later in the year.
Meaning that worst case scenario the film
gets bumped from the middle of 2018 to little
bit later it's supposed to be summer 2018.
They haven't put it on the schedule yet that's
only because they don't want to run into suicide
squad problems with rushing the film out,
just all going into the idea that they won't
start till it's ready.
Once they start shooting it.
Then they'll announce a release date.
So number six when is the movie actually supposed
to come out.
So originally Justice league two was scheduled
for 2018.
That was a way long time ago that they did
that.
So early on when they started to retool what
was going on with the DC extended universe.
They move that to 2019.
Just to give themselves some extra room in
the idea was is that the Batman movie would
move into that timeslot.
So sometime between May and July 2018.
Originally, like I said if it was delayed
it would just come out later in the year but
number five.
What do we actually know about the Batman
movie.
So actually know a few things it's Gotham
centric.
And even though were gonna see characters
from other films like the another been a lot
of cameos in previous DC films flash was in
the suicide squad movie, you'll see other
characters like Harley Quinn in the Joker
but they're not the main villains of the film,
it's primarily being described is in Arkham
prison break movie in the tone and style of
the raid redemption which is is this crazy
Indonesian action thriller or you fall the
small tactical squad of soldiers that have
to fight their way up to the top of a high-rise
floor by floor to take down a crime boss,
but in Arkham you're fighting your way down
to the bottom the lower you go the more dangerous
the criminals are so you just have to imagine
that all of Batman's worse villains are locked
up in there by Batman himself, and they get
released he's forced to fight his way down
to the bottom.
See you get to see the best version of Batman
doing all the most fun things chasing down
villains crazy moves lots of toys and crazy
intensity.
So, wait a minute number four if they already
have the idea why is the script taking so
long to finish.
Geoff John's was a co-writer.
He's like Mr. comic book, so writing the plot
is actually the easy part is really like the
dialogue the motivation know what, the interactions
between the characters are going to be that's
the hard part tefillin that's the stuff they're
working on to trying get right like who were
these characters in this movie and how do
the other films in form that.
So you have to remember that the new thing
at DC is that this is an extended universe.
The movies all have to fit together like puzzle
pieces, which makes it that much harder because
it used to be that you just make a Batman
movie even if you're making a trilogy.
You don't have to worry about other people's
films.
It doesn't matter what Superman is doing or
any of the other DC characters.
Now people like Geoff John's have been brought
on to do the Kevin fight he thing at DC and
just make sure that all the puzzle pieces
fit together, which makes it even harder to
write scripts for new movies.
So number three, what does that big puzzle
look like what is the overarching story Marvel
has their infinity gauntlet storyline that
started with the first avengers film for DC.
That's the cosmic threat of Darkseid in apocalypse.
Remember there are three mother box is on
the earth.
Those will be very important.
But so far, they've actually done a good job
of telling this larger story with the other
films even though they didn't have the idea
for Justice league till after they made man
of steel.
So it all starts with how the world reacts
to an alien with the powers of a God's that's
with the Superman man of steel movie was all
about people learn about him predictably the
entire world freaks out.
You have Batman view Superman in the aging
Batman who's been made cynical and paranoid
by his years of fighting crime.
So much so that he's taken the cow off treat
Superman like a threat if he's a threat than
we have to neutralize them.
So that's basically where you are Batman view
Superman, but at the end of that he and the
rest of the world are inspired by Superman
sacrifice.
So you get the suicide squad and you meet
people like Amanda Waller the worst human
being imaginable.
Even she respected Superman.
She says, at least he shared our values.
We might not be so lucky with other aliens
so that's where you have dark side apocalypse
Steppenwolf the Justice league movie, so Batman
asked to go around and recruit these people
without the help of Superman, everybody, love
Superman.
So there be no conflict if you were around.
That's why you have to reserve him for like
the big final fight, so Batman has to go around
and inspire the other members of the Justice
league that they need to come together so
Justice league.
You know within the context of the movie is
about people turning around and coming together
the Justice league movie is also gonna do
that for the fandom, but the problem is is
that nobody seen the trailer we haven't seen
the movie yet.
It just it isn't here yet sir buddy still
freaking out, so number two they get they
don't Justice league is that there still editing
it.
There might be a couple re-shoots their pretty
much done making the movie and there just
editing it in post production adding the special
effects.
That's what takes the longest to do all the
really small things.
So number one.
That means that there is a trailer it's sitting
on a shelf somewhere.
Zack Snyder confirmed that it was coming very
very soon.
About a month ago.
So why haven't we seen it yet.
Well like I said there was an election in
the US that causes a lot of economic uncertainty
so studios pull their spending back they actually
released trailers as part of ad campaigns
that involves them spending a lot of money,
so when they stop spending money just means
fewer trailers, so what they're doing is is
that is kind of waiting for everyone to chill
out and for a really big event with guaranteed
eyeballs and that is the Super Bowl which
is probably where will see that trailer but
if you're wondering why we haven't seen it
yet, you can just blame a lot of the economic
uncertainty happening right now in the fact
that all studios have been really pulling
back like even the Logan movie that's getting
ready to come out has not posted a ton of
trailers or footage like people are just holding
off a little bit until everything.
Chills out no worries it's gonna be awesome
if there's anything else that you guys want
me to explain to make you feel better about
stuff.
Just let me know in the comments there's going
to be a flash ring giveaway is every week
Marvel videos that I do have the Spider-Man
giveaway.
There's a special Holt buster giveaway that
I'm doing for my agents of shield videos.
So we all just need to chill out a little
bit it's gonna be awesome new agent to shield
will post in the morning though while you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
for all my flash predictions for the rest
of the season and you can click here to learn
all about Thor Ragnarok and how that leads
into infinity war.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!